[Applause]
partnering with apple music we found
three amazing Scouts to search the world
for Country musicians who don't
necessarily fit the mold but I'm gonna
take one mark
they say country music is three chords
in the tree but singing about life and
your life story it's a worship song to
Blue Collar nine to five people there's
definitely no singular way to define
country music but in my mind country is
defined by storytelling I see country
music one way for so long and now we're
finding it from all over the world my
artists I love all four of them and
Justin Camille Drew and Allen my four
artists are Alicia Michaela Isme and the
Congo Cowboys and last but certainly not
least Ashley Amber Juan delay the
Betsy's and Chuck Adams I really love
helping artists with advice that we had
to find out the hard and long way the
what way
Jimmy
thank you
country music was the first kind of
music I ever heard because my dad loves
country music
little tapes you know where you go and
go to the radio and try and record
yourself to do pop because that's where
I saw a lot of women who were successful
that look like me but every time I would
record a song it would come out so
twangy my friends they were like listen
girl these are great but you're a
country artist yeah
[Applause]
viewers can look forward to the
development of these artists we are
getting to work with the most boss
people in the industry Jamal McWilliams
amazing creative director production
designer Natasha Obie hatch the
legendary music director Mr Adam
Blackstone it's gonna be life-changing
it's time show the world your artists
and continue music and you belong here
it doesn't matter if you're from India
or Japan or Mexico you deserve to tell
your story and if it comes out country
awesome
[Music]